so the theme for this talk really is
thinking about how can android empower
you the developer to enable your app to
help users get things done and on the
team we really think a lot about how to
give your apps superpowers so you can
help users throughout the operating
system even when users aren't
necessarily in the full screen
experience of your app for this talk
will focus on three major areas that you
can take advantage of in Android Q the
first is with sharing next we'll talk a
little bit about notifications and
finally we'll discuss new details around
multitasking so in Android q we're
excited to have launched our redesigned
share sheet experience and there's a
number of improvements that we've made
for improving user's experience so the
first is around much improved
performance through a new API that we've
introduced that we're going to talk
about a little more detail
we've also actually updated the user
experience to make it simpler for users
to figure out where they can share their
content to so the share sheet is now
going to be organized into three
sections the first is going to clarify
what is the content that users can share
to and will provide a default experience
of what that looks like but you as a
developer can also provide additional
metadata to provide a richer preview
next up are our direct sharing shortcuts
where you can share within apps and then
finally our the app targets which have
been split into two sections some which
are suggested by the operating system
and then finally the full alphabetical
list and you'll see that it's a very
familiar interface to our launcher we've
also included a lot of new developer
customization options because we
understand that a lot of you a lot of
developers need to tailor their share
sheet for various use cases and we want
to enable and empower developers to do
so so one area that I want to highlight
in particular is the sharing shortcuts
API and really the goal of the sharing
shortcuts API is to allow users to share
more directly within your apps these sit
above the app targets that users can
share to and they can include targets
like a close friend that you are in
contact frequently with or an important
work folder
the performance benefit that they
provide users we're gonna actually rank
these ahead of the old chooser targets
and so we encourage your adoption so
users can take advantage of these in the
API I'm switching gears now into
notifications one thing that we looked
at at the start of this release is we
found that 75% of our users get at least
one buzzing notification or noise making
notification every hour and fifteen
percent of users get these every ten
waking minute every time waking minutes
so we thought how can we help you just
manage this overload and so we're
introducing the concept of gentle
notifications in queue and really the
goal of gentle notifications is to help
organize those important and valuable
notifications that users want to consume
but that aren't time sensitive and that
they can consume on whatever their own
schedule is and so the story is for
developers that you still set the
priority as you normally would
users can still adjust that priority but
now the system will also help adjust
that priority on behalf of users and
this will mainly target notifications
that are set with the default priority
in AOSP and in Hue the system will use a
heuristic model but we're also will be
incorporating on device machine learning
to make this a better experience having
organized notifications the next step is
to make them even richer and more useful
to users and so the way that we're
tackling this problem is by enhancing
these notifications with suggested
actions there are two use cases that
we're targeting for this the first is by
suggesting responses for users to reply
to with messages as well as providing
access to actions that are related to
the content of the notification so now
messaging notifications on Android will
contain actions to navigate to an
address that maybe your friend mentioned
for a restaurant to meet up at or to
open a URL that your friend wants to
check out finally we're really excited
to be announcing the bubbles API which
is a new multitasking feature for users
this allows users to keep track of their
most important tasks and be able to
access them at anytime anywhere in the
operating system how this will work is
you
we'll have a floating icon they can drag
it anywhere that is useful to them and
then they can tap to expand it to get
the full custom app UI we're
prioritizing we're prioritizing
communication tasks as those that can
bubble from a notification because these
are often the most important tasks to a
user on their phone well also users will
be able to pin the task from within your
full screen app for other use cases and
I think it's really useful to review how
this sits alongside our other
multitasking features namely a
picture-in-picture the big difference
between these features is that really
what picture-in-picture is meant to do
is provide users with the path to
visually monitor an important task and
it's meant to be a low interaction
feature you're something that you keep
us alongside you so that you can watch
while you're performing some primary
tasks so you can watch you know whether
a video going on or some directions that
you're following with bubbles it's the
the goal is to help users get to another
task as quickly as possible and they're
often high interactive UIs
so that's where a friend has messaged
you and you want to get back to them
quickly and you really want to do so
with the full fidelity of the messaging
app that you're using so you'll expand
the bubble in line without losing your
current context and then message to your
friend and go back to what your
previously doing we hope that this suite
of multitasking features unlocks a
number of new capabilities that your
apps can take advantage of and create
great new user experiences so now I'm
going to hand it over to Mike to talk a
little bit more about how you can take
advantage of sharing features
[Applause]
so we made some big changes to the way
that share sheet works in android q
let's see the hit the details that
matter most to you we know folks like
sharing straight to the person they want
to over the app they want with a single
tap who doesn't we're shooting to make
this experience even better so now we'll
show up to eight deep linked targets but
we know the loading chooser targets from
every installed chooser target service
on a user's phone can be a little slow
so to make loading deep link targets
faster we need a new architecture so in
cue we're extending the shortcuts API to
do just that publish a dynamic shortcut
and Android will load and rank much
faster than we could with direct share
previously we would only consider two
chooser targets per chooser target
service and now we'll consider all of
the sharing shortcuts that you provide
instead of just those two as an added
bonus because you're publishing
shortcuts those published targets may
also appear if you long press your app
and watching to give users the best
sharing experience we can offer sharing
shortcuts will supersede chooser target
service we've made it so that sharing
shortcuts will be ranked above all
targets provided by any chooser target
service on a user's phone so if you want
your targets to be seen on Q+ devices
please update your app and we've made
that relatively easy through Android X
implement sharing shortcuts with Android
X and you can get a back compat choose a
target service for older devices with a
tiny amount of extra effort the new API
to do this is pretty straightforward
make and publish a dynamic shortcut like
you would normally with the addition of
the required category field and the
highly encouraged person field adding a
well formatted person objects to this
and relevant notifications your app
pushes can help improve your ranking so
for your own sake please do so sharing
shortcuts
to be associated with an activity that
has a category matching your shortcut
category and that activity must have an
action send intent filter which you'd
have already if this activity appears in
the share sheet if you want Android X to
automatically generate a back compat
choose your target service for you
you'll need to include extra metadata
under that activity in the manifest
documentation on how to do this is
available now sometimes when you hit the
share button it's not exactly clear what
you're sharing we know this is a problem
and so to help with that we've added a
system-generated preview for several
different mime types it's now way easier
to copy text in some cases though even
seeing the exact text of the thing
you're about to share is hard to
understand think a long complicated URL
or really messy URI in these cases a
rich free view can provide your users
real reassurance of what they're about
to send so for text preview specifically
you can add a thumbnail and description
to provide your users that context I'll
pull this off with clip data and extra
title let me show you how make a sharing
a tent as you would normally
then add rich preview metadata to your
share intent before calling create user
stuff the description and extra title
and add the thumbnail to clip data as a
gotcha make sure to give us the right
permissions to read your thumbnail image
otherwise it won't appear see the add
flags method in this example we've heard
from developers that you really want a
way to provide hooks back to your app
from within the share sheet you can now
provide a limited number of chooser
target objects that will be shown ahead
of sharing shortcuts and any chooser
targets loaded from chooser target
services on the phone as shown in this
image you can also provide a limited
number of intents that point to
activities that will be shown ahead of
any apps
jes cheon's you can pull this off as you
might expect with extra chooser targets
and extra initial intents it's really
important to call out here that users
like and use deep link targets and app
suggestions for every intent and choose
your target you include it reduces the
number of suggestions available to your
users so please use this feature with
care through user studies we've learned
that folks almost always think of the
person and the app they want to share
too before they ever hit the share
button to make it easier for users to
find that app that they're looking for
we've alphabetized app share targets by
app name and important for you we've
changed the way that targets look we
will show your application icon as
defined in the manifest and ignore any
provided activity or intent folder icon
for app targets we will show the
application label very prominently it's
what we outfit eyes by and any activity
or intent filter label less so as you
can see in the example this is all the
help users quickly find your app so
please update your application icon and
label so users understand what they're
sharing too often the application label
alone is enough context for users
finally we wrap and shape app icons just
like launcher so please use adaptive
icons if you aren't already to make your
app icon look great there's a ton of
other things share she can do for you on
Android cue and you can find more info
and developer documentation coming soon
now over to taki for notification
actions
[Applause]
okay so in Android q the system can now
generate suggestion suggested actions
for your notification this happens for
messaging notifications the type of
notification is that we the types of
suggestions that the system now
generates include text replies or deep
links into apps so if you haven't if you
have a message a notification for
example we would automatically just
generate suggestions for this we think
this will help improve how users engage
with your apps notifications so for
example if with a friend of my text me
through your app it says hey let's meet
at this address
then the system can generate suggestions
such as yeah sure or no I can't make it
or give me a deep link to maps to see
the address or navigate to that address
the way this works is the system takes
the content of the notification runs it
through machine learning models and
tries to understand the the content of
that notification and what the user
might like to do do with this and then
it will pop those actions inside of your
notification let's have a look at how
you could I'm sorry there's one other
feature that you can enable with this
it's called tap tap to edit whenever the
system generates a text reply and
usually clicks this clicks to reply what
you could do is you can enable the fact
that the system were allowed the user to
set and to edit the notification before
sending it so for example if I was
responding to my friend and I click we
would love to I could continue to edit
the response before sending it say how
about I bring my dog or something let's
look at how you can make your apps play
nice with this new feature I'll show you
how you can enable them to save this
feature and I'll show you how you could
generate your own custom suggestions and
then I'll show you how you could combine
your custom suggestions with system
generators suggest
let's look at the code alright the first
thing you want to think about is to
remember that this implies automatically
to message notifications so if your
notification is of category is of type
category message then the system
automatically generate this suggestions
you can also make this happen for other
types of notifications if you think this
is applicable to them the way to turn
the feature on or off is if you want it
to turn us deep links the method you're
really looking for is set allow system
generated contextual actions you set it
to true to enable deep links and you
said to foresee if you don't want this
by default the system turns this on now
for text replies the method you're
looking for is set aloud generated
replies this was an API that we
introduced in Android P you set to true
then the system automatically generated
text replies for your app and you said
to force it would it won't do that and
then for tap to edit the method you're
looking for is set edit choices before
sending you want to set this to auto
when you do this your app will behave
like every other app on the device
however if you really want to give the
user a chance to edit the response
before they send it then you want to set
this to yes if you want a one-click
action then you want to set this to no
next slide cool
so as I said you could generate your own
custom replies and pop them into
notifications the way you do this is the
way the system really does this is it
kind of runs the content of the
notification through machine learning
models so you could train your models
but if you need help to do this you
could use ml kit and lock it now
features this new API called Smart reply
what you do is you take the text of your
conversation you pass it to smart reply
to suggest and then you return the call
back you return a response to your
callback with the suggestions you can
then take those suggestions I set them
with your notifications remote input by
calling set choices on it
whenever you set your own custom
suggestions what happens is the system
will not generate customs we're not
generally suggested for you anymore the
reason we do this is so that the system
the system generated suggestions don't
conflict with your custom ones but if
you really want to combine these
suggestions you could do this and the
trick to doing this is to understand how
the system really generates the
suggestions system uses a system service
called detects pacifier Texas right now
features this method called suggest
conversation actions and when you what
you do is you take the content of the
notification and you pass it through
this API the API then returns this could
the suggestions for you this suggestion
include text suggestions and deep links
into apps I already showed you how you
could set text replies to your
notifications but if you wanted to do it
for actions here's how to do it you take
the icon the title and the intent from
the action that was returned by the
textile sapphire and you use that to
build your notification you also want to
call set contextual and you set that to
true this will enable the system to
render your notification this your deep
links the same way the system renders
this in notification actions and that's
really the summary of all the things
that you really need to know about to
enable to get your app to play nice with
this new feature that we have in Android
queue next up is Maddie to talk about
bubbles thank you
hey everyone so bubbles is our new
notification based multitasking feature
in Android but before I talk about
bubbles I want to talk a little bit
about system alert window system alert
window has existed in Android for a
while and lots of apps have done really
cool things with it even though that
wasn't really the intention of this API
to begin with and also unfortunately I
apps have done some less cool things so
it's a bit of a security problem and it
was never meant to be a heavily used
user facing API so it also has
performance implications for the system
and Android as a whole is taking steps
to limit apps abilities to use this API
so okay this is where bubbles comes in
and bubbles is going to be offered as a
platform alternative to system alert
window so similar to how pip handles a
lot of the media viewing use cases
bubbles is here to handle the more
interactive use cases in queue bubbles
will be a Developer Preview you can find
it in developer options and you can
start playing with the API and getting
your apps built with it
so try bubbles give us feedback and it
will become the preferred path of our
system alert window in the beta builds
you'll see it turned on automatically
but it will be moving to developer
options okay so the anatomy of a bubble
you have a collapsed state and an
expanded state the collapsed State has
the ability to post an update out of it
and it's represented as a sheep with a
little flyout and then expanded stage
shows activity content and this supports
multiple bubbles if you've got more they
would show up in a little row okay how
do you build a bubble if you've ever
sent an Android notification or if
you've ever built an activity you can
build a bubble it's very straightforward
first you're configuring an activity
to display in a bubble then you're
building a bubble metadata object
attaching that to a notification and
sending the notification so let's look
at some code here we have our activity
definition in the Android manifest and
there are three things you need to have
set on your activity for it to bubble it
needs to be embeddable it needs to be
document launch mode always and it needs
to be resizable if your activity fails
any of these checks your notification
won't bubble it'll just show as a normal
notification and to construct bubble
metadata this is a new api on
notifications and you get the pending
intent for that bubble activity and then
this is very basic like all you need is
an icon and an intent the api has a
couple of other flags that you can look
at in the developer documentation but at
minimum you need the icon and the
activity then you attach this metadata
object to your notification so you build
a notification as you normally would
and then you just do that one call set
bubble metadata on it and then use
notification manager to send the
notification now I might have mentioned
that not everything gets to bubble so
bubbles are meant for highly interactive
use cases and they can be convenient but
they might be annoying if the user
doesn't find them handy they show up on
screen they take up screen real estate
and they want your attention so right
now we're focusing on messaging calling
and user initiated use cases if your
notification doesn't fulfill these
requirements it won't display as a
bubble it'll just show as a normal
notification would so the nitty-gritty
of this if you are messaging you'll want
to use message style and you'll want to
an inline reply action attached to the
notification if you're a phone call
you'll want to be category call you'll
want to have a person and foreground
service and then the user initiated use
case we're kind of covering when your
app is in the foreground so when your
app is in front of the user you can send
any kind of notification as a bubble and
that'll appear and once the app goes out
of the foreground that bubble will
remain on screen and you can continue to
send updates to it okay so just to
confirm did that thing I send did a
bubble and you can query notification
manager whenever something is bubbled or
when it's an active notification it'll
appear and get active notifications and
then you just can check the flags of it
this code gives a little bit of a sense
of it
find the notification that was so posted
bubble check if the flag for flag bubble
is enabled then you'll know okay so
that's all we've got a thank you for
coming to listen about with sharing
improvements and notification
improvements and bubbles and
multitasking and we'll be heading over
to the Android sandbox if you've got
questions for us and so please come find
us and thanks for listening today
[Applause]
[Music]